[Musique]
des médailles d'or pour ses dix danseurs
réunionnais porteurs de handicap en mai
dernier tous participé à la septième
édition du concours national handidanse
à bourges
ils ont présenté trois chorégraphies de
danses indiennes et de fusion bollywood
chacune récompensé par deux médailles
d'or et une médaille d'argent et on
s'est démarqué parce que c'était
vraiment comme on dit un arc en ciel de
bonheur pour pour la danse et sa rive
pour pour l'offrande de fleurs ils sont
que c'était la chorégraphie la plus
poétique et puis pour le duo avec marie
claire coup de foudre à bollywood la
danse la plus expressive donc pour moi
chérèque le pari est gagné pour ces en
dix danseurs de l'association sportive
culturelle de la personne handicapée à
sainte marie cette première
participation au concours national a été
riche en expérience une aventure humaine
où pendant trois jours ils ont pu
rencontrer et observé près de 600
danseurs en représentation ça fait du
bien on est heureux on ne pensait pas à
ça et voilà c'est venu c'était super et
puis c'est un trophée a donné envie de
continuer oui ça donne envie de
continuer mais pour ça il faut la
volonté et faut aimer et si ça c'est une
jouant pas ce que c'est on a fait des
efforts pour réussir et une fois qu'on a
gagné les prix bas on était très
contents de nos efforts c'est difficile
d'apprendre de répéter
non pas vraiment difficile mais bon il
faut quand même s'appliquer
les danseurs et leur chorégraphe seront
récompensés une nouvelle fois jeudi
prochain le département leur remettra un
prix pour leurs performances valorisant
ainsi l'image de ces réunionnais qui ont
du talent
[Musique]